the buffalo bills are seven and two for
the first time chris sims since
1993 left tackle dion dawkins already
said we don't want comparisons to the
1993 bills but that was the last great
super bowl bills team the fourth
consecutive super bowl appearance it's
been a long 27 years for bills fans they
have reason to be excited to damn shame
they can't attend the games
it's a damn shame no one can attend
games or at least most people can't
attend games although the cowboys did
have 31 000 in the stands yesterday
that's the most at any game so far this
season but the bills are getting it done
i talked to sean mcdermott after
yesterday's win over the seattle
seahawks and you know i they've done a
good job of just continuing to focus you
hear all the cliches but it is cliche
it's cliche for a reason
you have to forget about what's happened
and focus on what you're doing and yeah
you get beat by the tennessee titans and
it was a weird crazy coveted week where
the game gets moved to a tuesday night
and then you play on a monday night
against the chiefs and and uh you've
just got to keep working to get back
to where you know you can be and it took
them a few weeks they had that
lackluster game against the jets
they took the best that the patriots had
to offer and they found a way to beat
them and that i think psychologically
that's huge for the organization
mcdermott wants to downplay it now
because there's nothing to be gained by
peaking in the rearview mirror
especially when you know you've got the
patriots coming again later in the year
but that i i think that holding on and
beating new england
kind of unlocked the bills back to who
they were the first few weeks you throw
in the fact that josh allen was very
emotional yep his grandmother passed on
saturday he chose to play he had that
huge day i'm sure he dedicated
everything he did yesterday to his
memory of her his relationship with her
and you can find that extra kick
sometimes as a player and that makes all
the difference in the world you throw
all those things together and look i
don't know where the bills are going to
be when it's all said and done
but as we
categorize and prioritize and create the
hierarchy of who the real contenders are
i'm starting to maybe move yeah you know
refrigerator magnets i'm moving the
bills up toward the top again well i i i
mean i understand it i mean we've seen
we see flaws with other teams you know
in the afc you you can't you know we
know kansas city's king and pittsburgh
is obviously one and two in the afc but
after that
i think it's fair to say right now it's
a toss-up between who's number three i
know tennessee beat buffalo so you might
want to give that to them but you know
the chiefs they hung in there toe-to-toe
as we i mean the bills hung in there
toe-to-toe with the chiefs as we talked
about you know they weren't outclassed
in that football game by any stretch of
the imagination and even with some of
these ugly wins they had you know so
they lose ugly to the chiefs then they
have two ugly wins i do think it shows a
little bit about hey they can play that
style of football and not be out match
it doesn't always have to be josh allen
throwing the ball and everything like
that and then more to your sean
mcdermott thing mike you know the one
thing i'll be interested in watching
this film back a little bit is i want to
see some of the things they did on the
defensive side of the ball you know
they've been a little vanilla this year
i've been clamoring a little on my
podcast hey sean mcdermott get back
involved in the defense that's the
reason you're the head coach you got a
great defense of mine he really does
and you know they made some plays
yesterday to where
you know again they're like one of those
teams of their defense it doesn't have
to be great but if they can just not get
steamrolled like they did against the
chiefs in the run game or the rams in
that game when they let them come back
and do those type of things
you know they're going to be tough to
beat because josh allen and that offense
put pressure on you they do and the
defense if they can get your davies
white and jerry hughes and a pass rush
start to come back again a little bit i
think they will have a say in this afc i
mean again we know pittsburgh sitting
there at 8-0 pittsburgh
should have gotten beat by the dallas
cowboys yesterday i mean it was they
were just begging to get beat so they're
not like kings of the world by much they
are not and these two teams are going to
play each other in a few weeks it's
going to be interesting to watch how
that match-up plays out bill's beat him
last year i know there was no big ben
um but this is a dangerous football team
with those weapons in his right arm to
where i give them a shot in the afc
one of the arguments we got into last
week when we talked about power rankings
the steelers at one the chiefs at two
but you believe the chiefs would beat
the steelers
i think yesterday yeah i don't know how
it's going to be when they finally get
together yesterday the bills would have
beaten the crap out of the steelers
apples to apples based upon what we saw
in both games and that that extra little
something josh allen had yesterday it
maybe it'll still be there in a few
weeks and maybe the bills will now
ascend as one of the elite teams and
maybe the steelers are going to run out
of magic and you know and and quit
pulling this lucky card every week seven
of their wins have been
ugly wins or not convincing wins right
um and uh it's it's they've been pushed
around two weeks in a row
you know i'd love to see the chiefs and
steelers play we're going to see that
the steelers in bill's place so we can
at least resolve that one on the field
yeah no you're right we will see it but
i mean there's concerning things about
you know pittsburgh supposed to be the
big bullies on the block you know they
they haven't been that the last two
weeks the way baltimore ran it down
their throat hey dallas yesterday had
their way garrett gilbert picked them
apart at times now the beauty of
pittsburgh is always that they just
seemed to make a play at the right
moment on the defensive side of the ball
and they had a little bit of a shamrock
up their butt yesterday on the offensive
side of the ball with some of the
penalties that were called on dallas
they were fortunate that way but you
know again i think this is what just
goes back to this like yeah buffalo's
dangerous pittsburgh is dangerous all of
those type of things um
but that's where i just look at kansas
city and still think they're the kings
of the afc and i won't really think less
unless they go on some crazy losing
streak or losing the play or until they
lose in the playoffs uh i just think
they're going to continue to answer the
bell there's too many playmakers they're
physical on both sides and you know
that's what will be interesting down the
stretch here just can pittsburgh get
better can pittsburgh get better as far
as running the ball and doing stuff like
that on the offensive side of the ball
and then can buffalo's defense come
along a little bit and who knows maybe
they can challenge the chiefs and upset
them in the playoffs when that time does
come
you mentioned garrett gilbert by the way
i don't know if you noticed this but on
saturday the cowboys announced their
decision to go with garrett gilbert over
cooper rush right about the same time
another
maybe
nearly as significant decision was
announced nationwide it was right at the
same time anyway that's all we're saying
about that let's just take garrett
gilbert was a big decision son that was
a huge decision
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports